[Music]
okay you should just know that we don't
do this a lot so this is like a really
huge deal we want to invite you to have
lunch with us every day for the rest of
the week oh it's okay wholeness so we'll
see you tomorrow on Wednesdays we wear
pink my office is right across that Hall
any monkey business is ill-advised any
questions yeah I got a question it's
Barry Manilow know that you raid his
wardrobe give you the answer to that
question mr. bender next Saturday Oh
mess with a bull young man you'll get
the horns
shut it down boys please tell me you
didn't stay up all night drawing again I
know it's hard to start a new school but
there's a whole world out there there's
a whole big world in there everything
you have on is breaking rule number 22
what's rule number 22 the code of
conduct reading look what's happening to
your shirt nobody needs to see where
your chest hairs are going to be it's
good
[Music]
[Music]
so
our two worlds
Bueller Bueller Bueller
um he's sick my best friend sisters
boyfriends brother's girlfriend heard
from the sky who knows this kid is going
with the girl who saw Faris pass out at
31 flavors last night I guess it's
pretty serious Thank You Simone no
problem whatsoever life moves pretty
fast you don't stop and look around once
in a while you could miss it
[Music]
you